un calendrier de réouverture que déplore
une partie du personnel soignant en
réanimation en grève aujourd'hui
manifestations partout en france à paris
et à marseille également avec des
professionnels de la santé qui viennent
d'arles de toulon ou encore de fréjus
pour réclamer une formation spécifique
diplômante de meilleures conditions de
travail et des hausses de salaires
réaction en règle générale nous en tout
cas au ch de toulon on a la chance
d'être d'être doublé huit semaines pour
les infirmiers et deux semaines prend
les aides soignants mais au-delà de ça
pour acquérir les compétences
suffisantes et pour se sentir à l'aise
au sein de son travail et en toute
sécurité
il faut un an et on revendique eu juste
le fait que c'est absolument pas
revalorisés aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut
faire valoir c'est celle autre
spécificité et faire comprendre à la
population que que c'est pas seulement
pendant les crises cogic et on a des
soins spécifiques et qu'on produit que
ce genre de soins à tous les patients
c'est toute l'année c'est notre
quotidien et et sa demande des
compétences et des connaissances qui
sont pointues et qui sont poussés les
conditions c'est les même un peu partout
dans toute l'airé à de france je crois
les équipes sont fatiguées on est à bout
on arrivait au bout de un an à peu près
un an et demi de crise sanitaire
donc le coc vide on a réussi à
l'apprivoiser c'est plus ça mais c'est
les équipes sont épuisées
on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup donné
pendant cette crise est aujourd'hui
on veut une reconnaissance